E
DELIA SAID IT WAS INCLUDED IN
ERROR, BUT WHO THE HECK
BELIEVES THAT, AND HERE'S
CANDACE OWENS, HOST OF THE
CANDACE OWENS SHOW.
CANDACE, HA, YOUR REACTION, I
THOUGHT I HAD SEEN IT ALL BUT,
BUT I HADN'T.
>> HAD NOT SEEN IT ALL, THERE
WILL BE MORE TO COME, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION GOT CAUGHT
RED-HANDED, I WANT TO BE CLEAR
ABOUT WHAT THEIR INTENTIONS ARE,
WE KNOW THAT JOSEPH BIDEN DOES
NOT CARE ABOUT GRACE, HIS RECORD
WHEN HE WAS SENATOR TELLS US ALL
WE NEED TO KNOW.
IT'S TRUE THAT SHE BELIEVES
BLACK AMERICANS ARE THE EASY
PONDS, THE AD ADMINISTRATION
BELIEVES THAT THEY KEEP STROKING
RACIAL TENSIONS, THEY CAN TURN
BLACK AMERICANS INTO PERMANENT
SOLDIERS FOR THEIR POLICY.
BUT THEY ARE TRYING TO DO IS
REPLACE HARD APPLICANT RANKS,
ENGINEERING, MATHEMATICS, ALL
THAT STUFF, THEY DON'T WANT
KIDS TO GET THE RIGHT ANSWER,
THEY WANT THEM TO FOCUS ON, YOU
SAID IT, LAURA, EMOTIONAL
LEARNING, EMOTIONAL LEARNING IS
NOT RATIONAL LEARNING.
THEY DON'T TEND TO GO OFF AND
GET -- THEY TEND TO BECOME
ANGRY, RADICAL, AND EVEN
THROWING BLM BURNING
INDIVIDUALS, AND THOSE PEOPLE
ARE VERY EASILY TARGETED BY THE
GOVERNMENT, THAT'S WHAT THE
BIDEN RESUME ONCE.
THEY WANT PEOPLE TO DO WHATEVER
THEY SAY, TO BE ANGRY PONDS FOR
THEIR GOVERNMENT GAMES.
>> Laura: CANDACE, I CAN'T
TELL YOU HOW MANY DIVERSITY,
EQUITY, AND INCLUSION POSITIONS,
IF YOU DO A RANDOM SEARCH
ONLINE, WHICH I DID TODAY, THAT
SO MANY COMPANIES ARE LOOKING
FOR DDI OFFICERS, THE BIGGEST
SCAM GOING, GIVE INSTANT JOB
SECURITY, YOU CAN NEVER GET
FIRED, I GUESS, UNLESS YOU
ACTUALLY JUST TREAT PEOPLE AS
EQUALS, WITHOUT REGARD TO RACE,
THEN YOU WOULD BE FIRED.
>> AND THAT'S ANTITHETICAL TO
FREE-MARKET CAPITALISM.
THAT WILL DIE OUT BECAUSE IT CAN
JUST HIRE PEOPLE BECAUSE OF THE
WAY THAT THEY LOOK GREAT YOUR
COMPANY WILL LOSE AGAINST
THEM, IT'S RIDICULOUS, A POLICY
THAT PEOPLE ARE PEOPLE DOING TO
CAPITULATE WITH THE BLACK LIVES
MATTER RADICAL MOVEMENT THAT
WENT AFTER ALL OF THESE
BUSINESSES.
I DIDN'T THINK THAT WILL STOP.
I DON'T THINK THIS WATERING DOWN
OF THE EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM WILL
STOP.
I THINK WE'RE JUST SEEING THE
BEGINNING OF IT.
PEOPLE NEED TO REALIZE THAT
RIGHT NOW IN THE AMERICAN
SOCIETY, AND THIS IS A FACT,
NEVER HANDED OUT MORE DEGREES
EVER IN AMERICAN SOCIETY THAT WE
NEVER PRODUCE KIDS THAT ARE THIS
DUMB.
TALKING ABOUT BY STANDARDIZED
TEST SCORES, THESE KIDS ARE NOT
BECOMING SMARTER YET THEY ARE
GETTING MORE AND MORE DEGREES,
AND THAT IS BY DESIGN.
THEY WANT THESE KIDS TO BE
CONVINCED OF THEIR OWN
RATIONALITY, BE CONVINCED THEY
ARE SO SMART, AND BE SHOCKED
WHEN THEY CAN'T MAKE MONEY,
BECAUSE HE CAN'T MAKE THAT MONEY
IS A GENDER STUDIES OR IN LGBT
STUDIES MAJOR FOR FORECOURT
YEARS.
THAT'S NOT WHAT SOCIETY NEEDS.
I NEED SOMEBODY TO FIX MY AC,
NOT TO COME OVER AND TELL ME
THAT THERE ARE 26,000 GENDERS.
THESE KIDS END UP ANGRY, THEY
THINK THEY'RE MAD AT CAPITALISM
AND THE FREE MARKET, THEY SHOULD
BE MAD AT DEMOCRATS.
>> Laura: CANDACE, HAVE YOU
REALLY NOT SEEN HOW MUCH SHE
MAKES POOR PERFORMANCE, GETS
$20,000, AT SOME OF DO MAKE A
LOT OF MONEY, ON THE DEI STOP
FOR THE BLM STUFF.
BUT THAT'S A POINT WELL SAID.
CANDACE, YOUR POINT IS, KEEP
THEM DUMB, MAYBE KEEP THE